et c'est l'heure à présent de la chasse
aux fausses infos
[Musique]
intox est avec vous Anthony Saint-Léger
bonjour bonjour Raphaël et d'abord cette
menace qui fait froid dans le doigt en
pleine crise énergétique liée à la
guerre en Ukraine dans un clip diffusé
massivement sur les réseaux sociaux
l'entreprise russe Gazprom semble
promettre un hiver rude aux Européens
effectivement à ce clip il a été relayé
par plusieurs médias français et
internationaux d'ailleurs clip que l'on
va voir ensemble ce sont une minute 45
d'images que l'on va découvrir ensemble
voilà de quoi s'agit-il et bien d'un
homme que vous avez vu au début de ce
clip censé être un employé donc de gaz
Prom et qui coupe le robinet du gaz
signe donc d'un arrêt des livraisons de
gaz au pays européens car les images des
villes que vous voyez sont censées être
celles de ville européenne et vous
entendez cette musique et bien leur
rajoute une couche puisque c'est un
champ patriotique soviétique et son
titre est plus évocateur l'hiver est
grand
winter is coming comme on dit rien ne
prouve que cette vidéo en tout cas
anthony est l'oeuvre de gastrom
effectivement plusieurs éléments
permettent même d'en douter on va
procéder par étape d'abord si l'on se
penche sur les réseaux sociaux de gaz
Prom que ce soit le compte Twitter en
russe le compte Twitter en anglais par
exemple ou encore le site même de gaz
promet contact aussi le réseau social
russe ou même la chaîne Youtube de gaz
Prom et bien aucune trace ras de ce clip
donc de propagande imagine difficile
d'imaginer que le géant casier ne sont
féliciterait pas ou même n'en fasse pas
de pub voilà pour le premier indice
deuxièmement on va se concentrer sur les
images elles-mêmes et on va vous montrer
et bien que ces images sont un montage
d'image qui existait déjà sur internet
on va revenir au début du clip je vous
parlais de cet employé et bien c'est
bien un employé de gaz propre on le
retrouve d'ailleurs sur la chaîne
Youtube de gaspro mais vous le voyez on
est le 9 septembre 2019 donc rien à voir
avec le le contexte actuel on a été au
début on va aller cette fois à la fin du
clip avec cette image je vous la remets
mort c'est celle-ci il s'agit d'un
gratte-ciel qui avec une mère de nuage
qui émerge à travers une mer de nuages
ce gratte-ciel c'est le Lacta Center de
Saint-Pétersbourg là où Gazprom depuis
2019 à des locaux sauf que ces images
elles ne viennent pas de gaz propre
effectivement lorsqu'on fait une
recherche sur Youtube avec les mots clés
Lacta Center et nuages et bien on
retrouve l'origine de ce plan et pour
cause c'est ici une vidéo publiée sur la
chaîne officielle de la tour du Center
et vous le voyez avec cette date le 23
août 2018 voilà pour ce qui est du lac
tacenter on va s'intéresser maintenant à
d'autres images de
vidéo qui nous viennent en fait d'une
agence britannique dont vous le voyez le
logo ici qui procède à des vidéos de
réalisation architecturales et vous les
retrouvez effectivement dans la vidéo
virale en voici quelques exemples enfin
on va revenir là encore sur une autre
image de la vidéo dont je vous parlais
tout à l'heure ce sont les villes qui
sont mentionnées un exemple ici une
ville qui est censée je dis bien censé
vous allez voir pourquoi être européenne
sauf que lorsque l'on précède à la
géolocalisation et bien regardez ce que
l'on découvre c'est que cette image est
en fait
cette image de pont est un pont russe le
pont
vinogradowski pour je regarde mes notes
ce n'est pas facile vinogradowski et
bien ce pont il se trouve ici dans la
ville du sud de Russie la ville de
krasnokiak d'où vient ce montage et bien
il n'y a qu'un seul une seule personne
finalement qui en revendique la
paternité c'est ce journaliste Alfred
xino direct pardon godiref qui a été
interrogé ici par ce MEDA
d'investigation en russe en date du 6
septembre 2022 et il explique être à
l'initiative de ce montage de propagande
mais à des faits à des fins tout à fait
désintéressé sans contrepartie
financière une initiative avec l'une de
ces collègues c'est ce qu'il explique
dans cette article quant à gaz Prom et
bien il n'y a eu aucune réaction
officielle à la publication de ce de ce
montage malgré les sollicitations je
tiens à préciser de la rédaction des
Observateurs de France 24 une vidéo de
propagande oui mais faussement attribué
vous l'aurez compris à Gasprom donc
merci Anthony c'était un faux intox